should accept yourself just the way you
are what does that say about who I
should become is that just now off the
table because I'm already good enough in
every way so am I done or something get
the hell up get your act together adopt
some responsibility put your life
together develop a vision unfold all
those manifold possibilities that lurk
within be a force for good in the world
and that'll be the adventure of your
life
[Music]
and then they go back even further 100
million years before that so now you're
going back from 13.8 billion years let's
say today uh we're talking on a Friday
we go back there's some Friday 13.8
billion years ago okay if you just kept
going back seven times 24 and you just
keep counting the weeks and the years
and the month you'll reach some day and
and there'll be some day that three
minutes you know earlier the laws of
physics that we really understand know
and love gravity electromagnetism
um the strong and weak nuclear forces
that they all froze into the
configuration that we can understand
today
in other words once you go beyond that
and it is a type of event horizon in a
sense and that it may be forever
shielded from our vision once you go
beyond that that Gap you can no longer
speculate with the knowledge and
certainty and precision that we have
today so it's kind of marks a boundary
an ignorance boundary an ignorance
Horizon Beyond which we can only
speculate
[Music]
thank you
I'm looking very much forward today to
speaking with Dr Brian Keating I met him
recently in Miami looked through the
telescope at this beautiful San Diego
house on the coast he gave me a moon
rock which was very nice of him we had a
very good conversation I'm looking
forward today to talking to him about
the unfolding of the cosmological
landscape on the broadest possible scale
from The Big Bang forward as I mentioned
he's a cosmologist and also Chancellor's
distinguished professor of physics at UC
San Diego
he is also the author of more than 200
scientific Publications the equivalent
of between 60 and 70 phds by the way two
U.S patents and the best-selling books
into the impossible think like a Nobel
Prize winner and losing the Nobel Prize
the latter was selected as one of Amazon
editors best non-fiction books of all
time
he received his Bachelor of signs from
Case Western in 1993 and the PhD from
Brown in 2000 he was later a
postdoctoral fellow at Stanford and
Caltech in 2007 he received the
presidential early career award for
scientists and Engineers from President
George W bush for inventing the bicep
telescope located at the South Pole
Antarctica
he's also a commercial pilot and was
inducted into the International Air and
Space Hall of Fame in 2022
Dr Keating do you let's start out by
telling everybody what your primary
focus of concern is as a researcher and
then let's delve into what uh what you
can bring to people as a consequence of
that research what they need to know
about the the cosmic structure let's say
yeah so I always ask people you know
what's the most important day on the
calendar to them and usually I get some
version of you know Christmas or my
birthday or my you know hopefully for
them my spouse's birthday
um and it's an origin story and I think
humans are fascinated with origin
stories how did we come to be here
because we we don't know right we come
in as they say in media arrays in the
middle of the story and so how do you
get to understand what happened before
you the pre-history and the biggest
prehistory of all is how the cosmos came
to be and my research centers on the
oldest fossils of the earliest Epoch in
the universe so I'm an experimental
cosmologist you've discussed uh many
times with more theoretically inclined
individuals I actually build the
telescopes my colleagues and I my
students and I we build telescopes that
peer back as far as possible using light
now the light's not light we can see
with the human eye it's in the form of
microwaves because the universe has been
expanding for some 13.8 billion years
since a big bang and we'll get to the
question of whether or not there was
more than one big bang I hope later on
and the universe as it expands has
cooled off from a fiery hot hellscape of
an inferno to a more a more you know
moderate climate that will support the
existence of planets and and people and
all sorts of other uh interesting forms
of matter but the question of how the
matter came to be in the first place is
really the purview of what I do as an
experimentalist so my job as an
experimentalist is not to prove
theorists right it's to prove everything
else wrong and then what we're left with
will be a closer approximation to the
truth which is that we live in this
incredibly intricate fascinating
Universe filled with the most mysterious
forms of matter and even Consciousness
and and beings like you and I so that's
the the focus of the research and the
way that we do that is by building the
most precise and accurate telescopes
ever made and deploying them to the most
interesting Parts in the universe
including the South Pole Antarctica and
the high mountain desert of the Andes
Mountains in Chile as well as into outer
space so it's kind of every you know
boy's dream to grow up to be a rocket
scientist to build stuff to shoot
Rockets into space to to go to these far
extremes and uh the beauty of it is I
get paid to do it so that's my that's my
research Focus
so why don't we start with a comment you
made right at the beginning of that
explanation you said that you build
telescopes that peer back into time and
you might want to explain to everybody
there'll be lots of people who are
listening who understand that but
there'll be people listening who don't
why is it that when you build
um a technologically sophisticated
telescope that can peer out into the
vast depths of space that you're also
looking back in time
so all telescopes are time machines of A
Sort and that's by virtue of the fact
that light as fast as it travels and it
is the fastest propagating
um entity that we know about in all of
science it travels about this far about
one foot every nanosecond so if you
convert you know nanoseconds to Miles
and you convert uh uh you know a feet to
miles and nanoseconds to seconds it
travels about 186 000 miles per second
which is pretty darn fast but it's not
infinite so therefore whenever you're
looking at something you're not seeing
it as it is right now you're seeing it
as it was sometime in the past and the
farther away something is the longer the
light travel to reach your eyes or to
reach our telescopes and telescopes are
just eyes of a different sort there
might be sensitive to microwaves in the
case of the telescope that I build radio
waves gamma rays but just like your
eyeballs your eyeballs are too
refracting telescope UPS they have
lenses they have detectors and so when
we look at the Sun and I'm not
advocating as a professional astronomer
never look at the sun with your
remaining good eye but when you look at
the sun you're seeing it as it was and
that period in which it was was eight
minutes ago because it's 93 million
miles away and if you convert feet per
nanosecond or miles per second or miles
per hour you get it takes about eight
minutes for light to travel from the Sun
that means that Jordan the sun could
disappear and we wouldn't see it and we
wouldn't know about it really for at
least eight minutes and maybe even
longer so all telescopes are time
machines even the telescopes embedded in
our skulls
so how far back can we look now with for
example with the web telescope and
that's the new newest large scale deep
peering telescope that was launched into
space and
um how far back have we pushed the
Horizon of view now
so yes the James Webb Telescope was
launched on Christmas day in 2021 and
it's been sending back a phenomenal
images what makes the web telescope so
powerful is not that it can see farther
back in time although it can in a
certain sense but it doesn't have extra
magnification and that's not required to
see things that are farther away in
other words if you use a tiny little
telescope like the sort that Galileo
used back in 1609 to spot the craters on
the moon's surface you could use uh the
the Hubble telescope can also look at
the Moon and it won't see things that
are it'll see more detail on the moon's
surface but it won't see farther than
the moon because the Moon is in the way
now if you look where there's no moon
where there's no planet where there's no
galaxies where there's no absorbing
matter whatsoever then you're seeing
back to the creation of whatever light
your telescope is sensitive to now
visible light has only been around for a
few billion years because before that
time because of the universe is expand
tension that light has red shifted it
has gone from visible light to infrared
light which is invisible to our eyes but
highly visible and that is the Quarry
that the web telescope is seeking now if
you go farther than the infrared then
you come to microwaves which is what I
study so the longer the wavelength the
light you're looking at the farther you
can go back in time not because you're
impeded by something but because the
source the very source that you're
looking at has been diminished in
intensity and has been readden by the
expansion of the universe which is a
phenomenal discovery that we've only
known about for less than 100 years but
because of that Universal expansion we
can only see using particular
wavelengths of light and so that's why
the earliest light in the universe
there's no light that we could ever see
that is more primitive than the cosmic
microwave background that I and my
colleagues are studying so the web
telescope can't see far back in time as
we can but that's really irrelevant it's
designed to do something very specific
look at the first galaxies that form the
first stars that formed exoplanets in
other Stellar solar systems in our own
Galaxy and because of that it's a
phenomenal machine and is unrivaled in
its capability
so what what uh element of the let's
let's have you explain what the
electromagnetic spectrum is because
people are not going to necessarily know
what the relationship is say between
visible light and and and microwave
radiation they might not know that those
are very varying forms of radiation that
is very similar in its Essence and also
to explain why the red shift occurs
and how that was discovered I suppose
yes yes so a spectrum is a
characteristic of light light has three
major properties that we uh that we
discuss as scientist one is its
intensity how bright the light is and
the other is the color of the light and
the third is something called
polarization which happens to be my area
of subspecialty not political
polarization but it's an actual useful
form of polarization that has to do with
the orientation of the electromagnetic
field but all forms of light now people
hear radiation they get scared did the
bomb go off is there some nuclear react
no no it has nothing to do with that
it's just a generic term that scientists
call light of different wavelengths so
if you mention a rainbow which has an
infinite number of colors there's people
say there's seven colors the famous Roy
G Biv we learned about in elementary
school maybe but there's actually an
infinite number of colors because uh the
number that describes the color of light
is called its wavelength and the
wavelength of light is a continuous
number it can be any number can have any
number of decimal places so it's a
continuous number therefore there's an
infinite number of real numbers
therefore the spectrum is not discrete
in seven different increments so now
imagine you go beyond the red color you
keep going to the left of that red color
and actually this was an experiment done
by a very famous scientist and in
Herschel and even Isaac Newton did
similar types of experiments where they
took the sunlight they refracted it
through a prism so we've all seen these
prisms that disperse light and they had
light of different colors coming out at
different angles and that's the property
of a prism that causes it to make a
rainbow from ordinary white light and
what Newton Herschel did is they put a
thermometer they went into the red light
and they put a bulb of an ordinary
thermometer and they kept moving it
until it got beyond the red and then
they found that beyond the red color
there was still something coming in
causing the Mercury to rise in this
thermometer so there was clear there was
other light of a longer wavelength they
knew about the wavelength of light and
that longer wavelength is what we
associate with heat now the opposite
side if you go past the Violet side of
Roy G Biv
you come to something called ultraviolet
ultraviolet is also invisible and we
know about that from the Sun the
sunlight produces damaging UVA and UVB
radiation uh that's not any different
except for the fact it buys
characteristic wavelengths it's
wavelength is shorter than violet light
infrared is longer than uh than red
light and if you keep going in both
directions there's photons and
wavelengths of light in all different
directions add infinitum to the to the
high frequency or short wavelength and
it goes to Infinity in the other
direction you can have infinitely long
and that'll be called a radio wave so
that's the electromagnetic spectrum now
if you've ever listened uh to a a siren
approaching you've heard the familiar
Doppler shift that's interesting Doppler
Christian Doppler and Wolfgang Mozart
grew up in the same town in Salzburg
Austria I like to think they're they're
kind of enjoying the the irony of that
fact that they both have this
fascination with sound uh and its
phenomena and the expansion or dilution
of the wavelength of light is exactly
the result of a Doppler shift which is
exactly analogous to the the increase in
pitch and the decrease in Pitch that one
hears when an ambulance first approaches
you with its siren on that pitch is
increased and that's called a blue shift
meaning it goes to Shorter sound
wavelengths or it goes to higher pitches
as it goes away the opposite phenomenon
happens and that's why you hear this
characteristic rise
as it moves away from you and that's an
analog of red well the same thing
happens in light so if you have uh if
you're being approached by a a police
car and you try to get away from it it's
blue lights well it seem slightly more
red because it's effectively moving away
from you now you have to go a large
fraction of that in tremendous speed
that I spoke about earlier to get even a
tiny minute shift in the wavelength
either higher or lower so the redshift
that we observe for the universe was
discovered in the early 1900s and it was
discovered that we could see these these
little nebula they were first called
spiral nebula we didn't know if they
were part of the Milky Way galaxy some
said they were outside the Milky Way
galaxy but that didn't make sense
because put yourself in the frame of
mind of a scientist in the 1900s even
the great Albert Einstein thought this
was all there is to quote a song that
the Universe was the Milky Way galaxy
and that the it was Preposterous to
think about something beyond our galaxy
because that would mean beyond our
universe nowadays ironically we talk
about things beyond our universe and
we'll probably get into some of that
when we discuss the Multiverse in a
little bit but the universe was found to
be much larger than the Milky Way galaxy
in fact there were galaxies outside the
Milky Way galaxy that we observed the
most famous one being the Andromeda
nebula which is now called the Great
spiral galaxy Andromeda galaxy it's
actually the farthest thing Jordan that
you can see with the human eye if you
look up on a clear night you can see a
smudge and I'll show you the next time
you're in San Diego but I will show you
as clear smudge through my telescope and
you can see it through your naked with
your naked eye as well that smudge is
particles of light photons coming from a
Galaxy and those photons set out on
their journey to your eye when there
were hominids walking around on the
Serengeti uh Plains of Africa this is
the light that reaches us today is 3
million years old It's been traveling
for three million years since Lucy was
was Extant so that light from that
Galaxy is not being redshifted or blue
shifted tremendously but if you look at
every other Galaxy and we can see about
a hundred billion galaxies and each one
has at least 100 billion stars and each
one of those Stars probably has tens or
thousands of minor bodies asteroids
planets around them the numbers are
truly astronomical but if you go back
and you look at and we see a hundred
billion galaxies Jordan of those 100
billion galaxies all but 20.
show their light their characteristic
spectrum is shifted to the red some by
tremendous amounts and that implies just
as it would if you were at the center if
you were in the city and you heard all
these ambulances and every single
ambulance you heard it as if it was
moving away from you you heard every
siren's whale being redshifted to lower
and lower pitches what would you
conclude you would either conclude
you're at a very special location where
there was just an accident and the
bodies have been cleaned up and taken
away to hospital or that every part of
the city is experiencing all these uh
all the ambulance drivers are on strike
and everybody's leaving and so the
interpretation that Edwin Hubble began
to make in 1929 this is not a hundred
years old yet it's incredible
the observation that every Galaxy
exhibits a redshift that is every
Galaxy's moving away from the Milky Way
galaxy The Milky Way galaxy is no more
special or or more important than any
other Galaxy therefore all galaxies to
high approximation are moving away from
one another and that's an astounding
observation a physical fact that we
observe that when extrapolated to the
Future means the universe is going to
become more and more dilute and in the
past it was much more tightly condensed
compressed and presumably began it's
it's in its infancy with what we call
the big bang
so do you want to explain why the
farther galaxies are away the faster
they're moving away and is it also the
case that it's the redshift
that uh explains the fact that the night
sky is primarily black instead of lit up
all right is have I am I correct in the
latter assumption and and then let's go
to the former question yeah the latter
question is related to something called
olber's Paradox which is that in an
infinite Universe populated with an
infinite number of objects stars in this
case no matter where you were in that
Universe you would look out and your eye
your line of sight would terminate on
the star's surface somewhere they might
be really far away but eventually your
eye would come to rest on a on a star so
that would mean that it's a paradox that
our night sky we we have during the day
we see just one star but even at night
we don't see any stars that are any or
the night skies intensity is nowhere
near as close as the surface of the Sun
let alone the infinite intensity of an
infinite number of suns and it's as if
you were in a forest imagine a beautiful
boreal forest and uh and it's it's
effectively infinite the trees are a
finite width but they're and they're
spaced at some distance away from you
but there's an infinite number of these
trees and as you scan the around your
local Horizon all you would see is bark
all you would see are the trunks of
these trees that's alber's Paradox for
trees and what you're bringing up is
this notion that was interestingly
really encountered and and proposed and
even a solution perhaps by Edgar Allan
Poe the great poet uh in the in the
1800s he conjectured this idea that it's
kind of strange that well we we're told
we live in an infinite universe that
even the Milky Way galaxy could be
infinite in size we didn't know back
then in the 19th century and so it began
to be a paradox now the resolution of
that Paradox as you're pointing out is
is several fold one is that the
condition for the night sky to not be
dark is that the universe is infinitely
old
uh that the universe is infinitely big
and that the universe is static these
stars are not moving in that
simple-minded Paradox as the trees are
not moving in the old bridge Paradox
analogy for treats
those trees are stationary the forest is
infinite and the light has had enough
time to travel to your eyes because the
universe is infinitely old so if any one
of those three
propositions is falsified then you can
demolish the the Paradox as a paradox
and so the resolution interestingly
enough comes down to all three of those
are true false in other words it would
have been enough it would have been
sufficient to falsify one or more of
those of those three propositions the
universe is infinitely old infinitely
big and static but we actually know now
that the Universe isn't any one of those
three at least the universe that we can
observe so um now you asked about uh the
how we can think about the expansion of
the universe or how we can determine
that or how it was determined
um is that right can you remind me yeah
yeah yeah yeah well and why why the more
distant galaxies are moving away faster
that's right so the analogy that
astronomers use no analogy is perfect
right we're dealing with things not just
in a three dimensions of space but in
the fourth dimension of what we call
space time so we have to visualize
things that are really unvisualizable by
the human Mind by our own limitations
and so we make analogies so one of the
most common analogies is to think about
uh I'll give you two one is to imagine a
balloon with little dots drawn on the
balloon's surface the balloon surface is
two-dimensional as you ex blow up the
balloon the galaxies move away the dots
on the balloon surface move from one
another and they move with exactly that
property that a Galaxy that is one
centimeter our DOT that's one centimeter
away from another galaxy our DOT will
move twice as much in the same amount of
inflation or expansion as a Galaxy that
is half a centimeter separated or a DOT
two dots that are only five millimeters
apart from one another but that's
confined to a two-dimensional surface so
it's a little bit hard to maybe project
that into three dimensions in our mind
so another one that people use is
Imagine baking a raisin bread so a bread
and he's put in a bunch of raisins
inside of it that too has the exact same
property if you sit on any raisin inside
the bread and you watch what are the
other raisins doing that all will be
observed to move away from you there
won't be any gravitational attraction
between you and another raisin
so you'll actually observe what's like a
perfect expansion of the Universe from
your perspective remember I said there
are about 20 or more galaxies that are
gravitationally attracted to the Milky
Way and they are blue shifted because
they're Falling Towards us and will
eventually combine into a enormous Mega
Galaxy called a milk dromeda someday but
that doesn't happen for raisins or for
Dots in a balloon so the law that
describes that type of expansion in
either a raisin bread populated with
raisins in three dimensions or a balloon
dotted with magic marker marks in two
Dimensions those two
um those two phenomena are exactly
displaying what's called Hubble's Law
which is the velocity of every Galaxy we
see beyond a certain distance that's a
minimal distance that we don't have
gravitational interactions between us
and them that Galaxy will be moving away
directly proportional to what's known as
Hubble's Constant so the Velocity in
meters per second miles per hour you
know furlongs per decade whatever you
want will be directly linear it's the
simplest law manageable besides just a
constant it'll be moving linearly
proportionate to its distance away from
you and that's a fascinating observation
and that's the only type of observation
that can produce the type of structures
that we see in the universe in other
words it could have been traveling as
the velocity scaling as the square of
the distance the cube of the distance
the square root of the distance whatever
we would live in a much much different
universe and it wouldn't have any of the
characteristics that we observe
are you looking for an all-in-one
e-commerce platform that can help you
easily set up and grow your business
online look no further than Shopify with
Shopify you can quickly and easily build
your own online store manage your
inventory and accept payments from
customers plus Shopify offers a range of
customizable themes and templates to
choose from so you can create a
professional looking store without any
design experience it even helps
integrate with other popular tools to
help you sell across social media
marketplaces like Tick Tock Facebook and
Instagram with shopify's 24 7 support
and an extensive Business course library
that is available to support you every
step of the way Shopify is the Commerce
platform revolutionizing millions of
businesses worldwide if you're ready to
get serious about selling try Shopify
today sign up for a one dollar per month
trial period at shopify.com jbp go to
shopify.com jbp to take your business to
the next level today that's shopify.com
jbp
so I think when I read Stephen Hawking's
Brief History of Time which is it's
going to be 20 years ago or
approximately oh it's uh 40 almost 40
years old yeah foot guard well that's
what happens when you get old the decks
start to collapse so
um at that point my my memory if my
memory serves me properly
the standard cosmological model was that
we it emerged from a big bang and that
the Universe was expanding but that at
some point it would contract back on
itself and this was Hawking's idea
anyways and then collapsed back down
into uh into another Singularity uh
whatever existed before the Big Bang but
it's my understanding that over the last
few decades the evidence evidence has
accrued in an incontrovertible manner
that the rate of expansion is actually
increasing rather than decreasing and
that's I believe that's the great
mystery that's uh propelled scientists
who posit the existence of such
phenomena as dark energy have I have I
got that right and and what's the
current state of thought about the fact
that first of all explain why that's
surprising uh that the rate of increase
or the rate of expansion is increasing
explain why that's surprising and then
when you explain how that view has
changed over time and where we're at now
absolutely yeah so I got to hear Stephen
Hawking speak at the Royal Astronomical
Society meeting in London in 1995 and it
was back when he couldn't he couldn't
speak for a very long time so he wasn't
able to actually speak in real time but
he could move his fingers and he could
move his eyes and he could type on this
very special keyboard which the
ex-husband of his current nurse at the
time had invented that's a whole other
story I can recommend a book by my
friend Charles seif called Hawking
Hawking and it was sort of the business
of Stephen Hawking and I uh he could
answer one question it would take him
about 10 minutes to answer a question
someone asked him in the audience
Professor Hawking you're rumored to be
the most brilliant man alive and yet
you've written this book that almost no
one besides you know a younger Jordan
Peterson perhaps had red cover to cover
um why did you write this book and he
answered in his computerized synthetic
voice because my daughter needed to pay
for college and uh it was just
interesting that this great man this
great intellect you know trapped in this
body that had you know been robbed of
all of its its physical kind of
maneuvering and so forth was was so
facile with his mind it was really an
incredible thing to see uh when when
Hawking wrote that book it is true uh
the expectation was that the Universe
would eventually collapse on itself
would eventually undergo what's called a
big crunch which is essentially the the
opposite of the Big Bang we would
observe if we were living billions of
years hence the story went that we would
see not galaxies being redshifted but
galaxies being blue shifted because
we're all going to combine and
eventually into a collapse of an
enormous if you like gravitational Time
Bomb uh that would probably play out
over you know billions if not trillions
of years so I kept advising people to
keep pay their taxes but at the at the
at the time we didn't know about the
substance called Dark Energy and what's
so surprising about that and what kept
Einstein really flummoxed for the first
part of his of his career
was that we only knew of a few different
forms of matter and energy in the
universe we knew of matter stuff the
stuff that we're made up of and we knew
of light and in a universe that only has
matter and light it's impossible to not
have a gravitational collapse just as
the same is true if I take an object a
ball or an apple and I throw it up with
some velocity it will still come back
down unless it reaches what's called
escape velocity and the perplex the
perplexing thing about Einstein in
general relativistic gravitation that
still mystifies me and experts is that
when you add matter to the universe it
actually makes it expand faster which is
counter-intuitive you would think if
there was more gravity in the Earth's
surface the ball would or the Apple
would actually fall down even quicker
which it would but uh but in in the case
of when we described the expansion of
the universe we're talking about its
velocity not its acceleration so there's
a crucial distinction the universe can
have objects moving faster away from
each other and that doesn't involve of
necessarily their acceleration so what
Einstein did to counteract that fact he
was a pretty smart guy right he looked
around he said well the universe doesn't
seem to be collapsing so there must be
some hidden form of energy that we don't
observe and that obser unobserved matter
he called the cosmological term or
cosmological energy source we later call
it the cosmological constant and now we
call it dark energy as you as you
proposed what that does is by adding in
matter you get anti-gravity or you add
an energy Pure Energy you get a form of
anti-gravity almost as if you know it's
the comic book Heroes a dream that you
could suspend gravity that you could
freeze the motion of objects that tend
to want to combine with one another so
he then had a mechanism contrived as it
was to explain why the universe appeared
static as it did in 1920 and 1919 but
then as I mentioned earlier when Hubble
observed the universe is in fact not
static hair Einstein the universe is
expanding then Einstein had the
Brilliance the humility and the
confidence to say I was wrong and
supposedly he called the insertion of
the cosmological term his biggest
blunder right now so he was trying to
account for the fact let's just to just
to get the chronology clears at that
point the universe appeared static and
Einstein was trying to figure out why it
wasn't collapsing onto itself and so he
proposed a constant which you equated to
something like an anti-gravity energy
but then the problem turned out to be
even worse than it seemed to be because
it was not only not collapsing and not
or sorry not static and not collapsing
it was expanding yeah so and that's the
mystery that people are trying to
address well still today with the
hypothesis of something approximating
dark energy
that's right so the dark energy
phenomenon causes not only a reversal of
the collapse of the universe's in-fall
of all these galaxies or raisins or uh
that would be coming together it not
only freezes them in their tracks it
actually reverses that process so
instead of just expanding linearly
smoothly as Hubble would Envision us
doing actually the universe starts to
accelerate so it's as if you're pushing
down on the cosmic accelerator pedal
these galaxies are not only moving apart
but tomorrow they'll be moving apart
even faster at a given distance they'll
be moving apart faster than they are so
I always joke you know it's uh it was a
blunder of Einstein to call that blunder
his blunder uh because it wasn't a
blunder at all and I I always say I like
to throw in you know it's too bad that
he made that blunder otherwise he could
have had a good career but in this case
when we when we look at what Einstein
was conjecturing it came back
unavoidably in the late 1990s through
the observation of what are called type
1A supernovae which are just used it's
not important to know what they are
they're exploding stars and they're
fascinating objects in their own right
but they're really used as the sirens on
the ambulances at Great distances so in
uh in in 12 rules for life you talked
about the value of precision of speech
well the most important thing for
cosmologists is precision cosmology when
I started graduate school in the in the
1990s and the mid 90s we didn't know if
the universe was 10 billion years old or
20 billion years old now we know it's
13.824 billion years old and we have a
Precision of less than one percent and
we also have an accuracy in other words
we have calibrated that number and
removed systemic contamination from that
number it's really phenomenal I mean at
that time we knew of objects that were
older than the universe supposedly there
were objects called globular clusters
and they were older than the universe
that's like finding out that you're
older than your mother I mean it's very
bizarre situation and quite frankly it
is embarrassing to cosmologists now we
know with extreme Precision but that
with that Precision comes great power
and that power allows us to assess what
is the nature of this dark energy
potentially
and not only that what is it doing to
our future understanding of where the
universe will continue to develop in the
in the Far Far distant future and so if
the universe truly has this dark energy
chimeric form of energy unknown
completely you know unlike anything
we've ever had an experience with that
type of energy will eventually Drive the
universe potentially in a variety of
different ways none of them good uh but
luckily they don't come about for tens
to perhaps hundreds of billions of years
when the universe might physically rip
apart there could be aspects of
space-time that at all locations develop
what we call singularities the breakdown
in all the laws of physics and certainly
long before then we will have stopped
having the ability to do astronomy or
cosmology we will no longer be able to
see any other galaxies after a certain
point after the universe has expanded so
much those galaxies will all be
redshifted so far out of observational
constraints that we won't even know we
live in a galaxy we'll just think this
is the entire universe so ironically
we'll be back to the way the State of
Affairs was in pre-1929 uh planet
Earth's understanding of cosmology and
with the Precision that I mentioned
before that we know the age of the
universe we know the expansion rate of
the universe we can do astounding things
we can go back in time and ask just as
we do with uh with I remember when I
when my children turned two years old
you take them to the pediatrician's
office
and they measure their height and
basically they've got this rule of thumb
based on the statistics of 100 billion
people that have lived on planet Earth
to date that the child will be about
twice as high twice as tall as he or she
is at age two I think I'm getting that
right I am a doctor but I'm not that
kind of a doctor right so uh you'll have
to check those numbers but they
basically extrapolate so imagine if you
went and you go to the pediatrician and
then you come back in 10 years 15 years
20 years and the kid is like 30 times
bigger than that height or or one-tenth
is tall well you'd say this is crazy
there's something strange going on your
tables are all messed up and and your
actual statistical sample is not a good
representation of the parent population
no pun intended so the question becomes
how accurately Can you estimate how fast
the universe will be expanding today
versus 13 billion years ago and there's
what's called attention because the two
numbers disagree and they disagree by a
violently inacceptable amount
they the measurements that we do with
the cosmic microwave background
radiation suggest a universe that is
very in billions of a billion years
um uh younger if you like than the
universe that we see using the type 1A
supernovae and that tension is a lot a
billion years is a big difference and so
each one is precise that's that's the
current that's the current probe a
current problem that's a current problem
we don't know the Hubble constant's
value it disagrees at what's called five
standard deviations so there's a one
part and several million that it could
be a statistical fluke and they're both
they're both actually the same or it
could be that the physics of the early
universe that I study is very different
than the physics of the late time
universe that my colleagues who study
supernovae study
lean into the simple benefits of proven
science with Elysium Health Elysium is
dedicated to tackling the biggest
challenge in health aging they work with
leading institutions like Oxford and
Yale and they have dozens of the world's
best scientists working with them eight
of which are Nobel Prize winners
elysium's new biological age test index
provides you with nine system ages these
are the biological ages of different
parts of your body including your brain
your heart your livers and even your
metabolic system not only will index
give you a measure of how quickly you
have been aging but it can also help you
make simple small changes to your
day-to-day life with the potential to
change how quickly you age in the future
the process of taking index is very easy
you send in a saliva sample that you can
collect from the comfort of your home
using that saliva sample Elysium
scientists will analyze your epigenetics
and measure what's happening day to day
in your body Elysium also offers Cutting
Edge solutions to help support your
metabolism and immune system like signal
which helps you maintain healthy
metabolism and format which is designed
to support a healthy immune system
Elysium health is a special offer for Dr
Jordan Peterson listeners go to
elysiumhealth.com index and enter the
code jbp50 at checkout to save 50 off
your index test that's elysiumhealth.com
index enter code jpp50 for 50 off
so okay so let's walk back
13.824 billion years now in principle
correct me if I've got any of this wrong
all of the matter and energy that
constitute the current Universe visible
and invisible is collapsed to well to to
a point that isn't even a pinpoint it's
infinitely small and infinitely dense
and there's a cataclysmic explosion
that's the big bang that's still part of
the standard cosmological model still an
accepted
let's say fact and then let why don't
you walk us through what happens as the
universe unfolds from that point onward
including speculations or known facts
about the early the difference between
the early periods that you just
described maybe even in terms of
fundamental
cosmological laws and later periods now
and and we might also throw in this
caveat too is that
as far as I've been able to determine
um it's still axiomatic presupposition
among scientists that the laws of
physics that obtained at the point of
the singularity are not the same laws of
physics or at least can't be shown to be
that govern the universe as it's
currently unfolding so let's go back and
we'll walk through all of that actually
yeah I'm glad you said it in those terms
it's it's actually better to start not
with the beginning which is ambiguous
which is hotly debated which is
contestable and those are all good
things about the scientific process uh
but actually to start with today so
let's go back from today when we think
we understand the laws of physics that
that are uh you know presented to us and
go back in time to a point
um at before which we don't understand
the laws of nature because if you start
you know if you start from a point of
ambiguity and uncertainty and then you
attempt to extrapolate forward you're
less likely to get the right answer than
if you kind of go back historically and
ask when do we lose sight of the plot
line when do we lack our understanding
of the laws of nature so starting from
today we see four forces of nature there
there's two nuclear forces called the
strong and weak force that govern the
behavior of atoms and radioactive decay
and then there's the law of electricity
and magnetism that govern everything
from electromagnetic communication like
we're doing right now to refrigerator
magnets to magnetic levitation and and
future you know helpful uh
Transportation mechanisms uh and then
there's the law of gravity which is
perhaps most familiar to us when we try
to get out of bed every morning we're
fighting against the entire mass of the
Earth with our meager masses hopefully
uh you know maintaining uh the the
battle every day to get out of bed and
make your bed in the morning so this
phenomena these four phenomena are
familiar to us and we can actually go
back a great distance in time and and
and even staying only in space where we
are right now let's take the Earth back
in time we go back four billion years
the earth condensed out of the shrapnel
of a supernova that had exploded perhaps
a billion years before that in our local
arm of the Milky Way galaxy let's go
back a few more billion years the dark
energy that we spoke about earlier began
to dominate and the universe started to
accelerate faster and faster well that
still is in the laws of classical
physics and quantum physics that we
understand let's keep going back now
we're back say 10 billion years ago the
first the first stars that were ever
made are all long gone they've all blown
up into these type type one population
three events uh that the web telescope
is hopefully going to shed more infrared
light on and then they go back even
further 100 million years before that so
you're now you're going back from 13.8
billion years let's say today uh we're
talking on a Friday we go back there's
some Friday 13.8 billion years ago okay
if you just kept going back seven times
24 and you just keep counting the weeks
and the years and the you'll reach some
day and and there'll be some day that
three minutes you know earlier the laws
of physics that we really understand
know and love gravity electromagnetism
um the strong and weak nuclear forces
that they all froze into the
configuration that we can understand
today
in other words once you go beyond that
and it is a type of event horizon in a
sense and that it may be forever
shielded from our vision once you go
beyond that that Gap you can no longer
speculate with the knowledge and
certainty and precision that we have
today so it's kind of marks a boundary
an ignorance boundary an ignorance
Horizon Beyond which we can only
speculate but speculation is fun and
it's great to do and and I I appreciate
it as much as my theoretical colleagues
do remember I'm an experimentalist I
look at the shrapnel and the fossils and
what's left from the universe that we
can observe today even if it's very old
like the light of the cosmic microwave
background it's very old it's the oldest
light in the universe I still can use
that to glean information about that
period you know three minutes after
midnight on some Friday
13.8 billion years ago right so we can't
look all the way we can't look all the
way to the Big Bang itself we can look
some fractions of seconds after the big
bang when the law cause of physics
spring into existence and we have the
beginnings of the interactions between
matter and energy that we see today but
there's a border there prior to that um
that that we can't peer into at the
moment now talk to people tell everybody
about what the cosmic background
microwave radiation is and why you study
that and how that enables us to peer
back really to as close to the beginning
of time as we can manage yeah exactly so
the cosmic microwave background is the
leftover heat from the fusion of the
very first elements on the periodic
table of the elements so the lightest
elements in the universe are hydrogen
and helium and they have isotopes each
one has a couple of different isotopes
meaning they have more or fewer neutrons
in their nuclei these are not atoms
though these are just the nuclei of what
would eventually become the chemical
elements and atoms so the nuclei are
fused in the first few minutes of the
universe of our current observable
universe I have to be very precise here
we can't say the Big Bang was the
beginning of time we don't know that
most people's
assume that the Universe with the
universe's origin with the big bang came
the beginning of time that raises all
sorts of of hairy paradoxes that are
really quite difficult to approach both
from the laws of physics perspective but
even from metaphysical perspectives you
know what was how does time come into
existence when when there was a moment
before that existence was even possible
can you even conceive of such a thing
how do you get the mode of change the
mode of Force if you will to go from X
to Delta X Plus Delta or t plus delta T
if there was no time at the at the zero
point so these are metaphysical
questions and I should say there are
many eminent and serious cosmologists
who do speculate what would the universe
look like if there wasn't a quantum
singularity at the origin of time now
there were no origin of time if you will
whatsoever and you've spoken to some of
them Roger Penrose and and others but
but the point being that there are
alternatives to that now 99 percent of
my colleagues don't really pay much
attention to those models but I think
it's important to at least not give the
impression that we know for certain the
universe had a Quantum gravitational
singularity that sprang time into
existence as you said before you know
there's infinitesimal amount of uh of
space and in that space was all the
matter in the universe Jordan we don't
know that that is a possibility and in
fact that's the most popular uh
possibility amongst my colleagues but
again I'm an experimentalist I don't
come up with these theories I try to
prove these theories wrong so one of the
things that I'm doing with the cosmic
microwave background because it is the
oldest light in the universe and because
if you think about the motor homunculus
of a human being we get most of our you
know kind of attention our cortex our
brain pays attention to light the visual
cortex and also our hands and our motor
you know our motor system and you know
this infinitely better than I do Jordan
but but light is such a powerful tool
that we should do everything we can to
exploit all the information and these
precious few photons that are still left
over they're still coming to us they're
still saying hello here I am I am a
relic fossil and I've traveled through
time like a time machine to get to your
telescope here in Chile or Antarctica
and I'm going to tell you about what it
was like when I was born now that's
enough for me to kind of you know just
stretch my imagination build new
instrumentation but of course it's fun
to speculate on what happened before so
I just told you these are the oldest
particles of light so the only thing you
can say right now is that we can't use
light to find out what happened before
these photons were born these Cosmic
microwave background photons came to be
so that doesn't mean that there's
nothing we can use because nature is
clever and there are many different
forms of matter and energy that we can
use to trace the early Universe
phenomenon if indeed if and only if
there was a universe prior to say the
Big Bang or prior to the formation of
these uh these these ancient Relic
photons so one other form of radiation
it's not electromagnetic radiation it's
called gravitational radiation
gravitational radiation arises Whenever
there is matter in motion and whenever
space-time reverberates so famously it
was discovered by three friends and
colleagues of mine and their team called
the ligo experiment in 2015 in September
2015 they caught the in spiral of two
black holes each one 30 times the mass
of our sun they were moving a fraction
of the speed of light a very high
velocity they eventually call us into
one fused exactly of the analogy is I
like to use is fused into a giant black
hole but that black hole had a mass of
say 59 times the mass of our sun so
where did that extra one mass of the sun
go well it went into shaking up the
fabric of space-time itself and that
reverberation of space-time is called a
gravitational wave or gravitational
radiation gravitational radiation
penetrates everything when I shake my
fist here in San Diego you feel it there
uh on the East Coast be caught but it's
minute and it's overwhelmed by a
multitude of other sources of of local
gravitational field Distortion but as
these waves of gravity travel through
space-time they affect all matter and
they go through all matter and so we
would actually weigh slightly heavier
and then alternate we'd away slightly
less as the gravitational wave came into
the room that we're in right now that's
the effect that propagate does that
propagate at the speed of light yeah it
propagates at the speed of light it also
has the virtue that they don't they
don't Decay there's nothing for a
radioactive there's no radioactive decay
of gravitational radiation they're just
like light except they go through
everything so if the universe produced
an enormous amount of gravitational
waves capable of being detected a
billion light years away from these two
black holes that I described before they
were located one billion light years
away in a galaxy we don't know exactly
which Galaxy they were in but they
crashed together in a galaxy far away
from the Milky Way galaxy a billion
years ago those waves of gravity
traveled at the speed of light for a
billion years they entered into two
different telescopes on Earth and they
displaced those telescopes by less than
the diameter of an atom and these
incredible researchers were able to
detect this and they've done it 100
times since so it's a it's a Precision
science just like Galileo first using a
telescope to look at the Moon the moons
of Jupiter the rings of Saturn Etc that
opened up a whole new uh regime of
astronomy not just to look at the moon
but to look at the entire universe using
optical telescopes they revolutionized
that now Jordan if indeed all the matter
in the universe was as we know at one
point the universe was Far Far smaller
it was at least a thousand times smaller
than it is now in every Dimension that
that means it was it was a thousand
thousand thousand or a billion times
smaller in volume than it is now when
the cosmic background radiation was
released or produced about 380 000 years
uh after the initial Singularity or
after the origin of our current
observable universe if two little measly
black holes you know uh if just they're
crashing together can cause a lot of
gravitational radiation think about all
the matter in the entire universe all
the black holes that would ever be and
all the stars all of our matter that
made us up all the light all of it
coming into existence at a certain time
you would expect that that would make an
enormous amount of gravitational
radiation and you'd be right and so that
gravitational radiation would then
propagate through the universe and
eventually it would encode and encrypt
Its Behavior on What's called the
polarization of the microwave background
remember I said light has three
properties we talked about we talked
about the three properties the intensity
the brightness of the light we talked
about the color of the light or its
Spectrum well the third and least known
the properties of light because our eyes
aren't sensitive to it uh is the a
polarization state of light right now it
turns angle of try travel essentially
it's the oscillation if light's a wave
like you and I holding a rope and
oscillating a rope up and down it's the
plane that the Rope is oscillating in it
could be horizontal it could be vertical
it could be any angle between it turns
out the gravitational waves have a
beautiful propensity to turn the
polarization of the microwave background
in a very particular orientation and we
can by mapping the orientation of the
microwave background and its
polarization we can Define the existence
or lack thereof of waves of gravity
called gravitational radiation and if
detected that doesn't prove a theory
that we can get into called inflation
which is the most popular a cosmogenesis
model that we have but it gives very
very very strong circumstantial evidence
for it but again I'm an experimentalist
so what do I do Jordan I try to kill
other theories well it turns out our
good friend Roger Penrose he has a
theory that there should be no
polarization of this kind in other words
Jordan if I observe my team and I
observe this particular polarization
configuration it doesn't prove somebody
right it proves Roger wrong it proves
other colleagues wrong as well that have
alternative hypotheses and what are
those alternative hypotheses well
they're very fascinating because they do
not involve inflation but they also do
not involve a singularity at the origin
of time there is no origin of time in
most of these Alternatives so by
observing the signal we kill those
models off and what's left is a closer
approximation to the truth
and did you and Did You observe this
polarization yes we did and then yes
that's a that's a that's a hangover if
I've got this right that's a hangover of
events that occurred before the light
itself that you're measuring which is
the microwave radiation electromagnetic
radiation that it was extant about 380
000 years after the big bang and so it's
been oriented in a manner by something
even earlier than that
that's right oh I read some I read a
counter Theory I think when I was
investigating your work for our podcast
that is it the case that there are
people who claim that the polarization
that you detected was a consequence of
of the interaction
between light the light you're observing
and and and dust that's spread out in
the cosmos that and that's not a
consequence of this early gravitational
of these early gravitational waves yeah
so this is a very very important chapter
not only in my life but it's it will be
talked about in future years as an
example of of how science actually gets
done and it's the subject of my first
book losing the Nobel Prize and it's the
story of how uh that a scientist can
become obsessed in this case the
scientist is me it's a memoir of my
career trying to detect these early
reverberations of the universe's
space-time structure in order to see
whether or not inflation or an
alternative took place to ignite the hot
big bang that we do observe and have
have stacks and reams of evidence to
support so the existence of of matter
the existence of the CMB the existence
of galaxies and expansion those all
support the fact the universe was in an
extremely hot and dense State early on
in its history but they don't provide
the mechanism by which that came about
and I always say it's like this Jordan
when somebody says you know we're going
to take biology class on the first day
of biology class when when you were in
in college they don't start off with the
origin of life in the universe they
don't even start off with the origin of
DNA right it's almost as if the origin
of the universe is outside our Meta Meta
cosmologically related to the expansion
and the properties that we observe as
cosmologists so it's almost expecting
too much of us to say well we also know
how the universe came into existence but
again it's super duper fun to speculate
about things that you can't observe and
maybe will never be observable so I
wanted to do this I wanted to observe
the early universe and its infant State
I wanted to do that for two reasons I've
always been fascinated by the biggest
possible questions I always I grew up
I'm Jewish but I grew up as a Catholic
uh uh uh you know young man I was an
alter join the Catholic church I never
had a bar mitzvah and so at the time
when I should have been having apartment
so I was in a Catholic Church I was
interested in the origin of the universe
trying to know if God existed
and trying to understand our place in
the cosmos and I didn't care about kind
of the stamp collecting aspects of of
life I didn't care about parties and all
sorts of other things status Sports I
just wanted to understand Math Science
and use my telescope and those were my
those were my real Fascinations as a
Young Man uh later in life I became uh I
said I was I'm Jewish both my parents
are Jewish my father was a great
scientist his name is James ax I don't
have the same last name as him he
divorced my mother and father got
divorced and I live with my stepfather
who became my stepfather and he adopted
me and I lost touch with my biological
father for many many years for 15 years
I didn't see him and in that period of
time I knew he was a great scientist he
was a great mathematician he was the
youngest tenured professor of
mathematics at Cornell in their history
and I think he still holds that that
distinction he went on to have a great
career and I didn't see him and I
actually was adopted by my stepfather
and I kind of had this rivalry with him
Jordan and you can psychologically
diagnose it as you like but just as a
boy might want to be a better football
player or wrestler than his father I
want to be a better scientist than him
as great a scientist as he was he never
won the Nobel Prize and I realized I
could you know kind of one-up this old
man who had abandoned me and my older
brother decades earlier and I could do
what he did not and best of all I could
do it by having the most doing the most
fun thing I could possibly imagine
building telescopes and studying the
biggest picture topics so this became my
obsession I became obsessed with this
and later on a proposed an experiment
with my mentor and friends at Caltech
where I was a postdoc
to go back in time as far as we could go
back building a telescope called bicep
which I coined the name it means
background Imaging of cosmic extra
Galactic polarization but it's a play on
words because that polarization signal I
told you about Jordan the orientation is
called a curl so it's called a coral
type motion it's gonna be funny there's
a profound nerd joke for you it is yeah
you don't want to catch that one before
I got to being a purveying dad jokes I
was purveying nerd jokes so that
experiment did detect we detect we
claimed we detected the imprimatur of
inflation in other words we claimed that
we saw the twisting roiling pattern of
polarizations called curl mode
polarization that was thought to be
conclusive if circumstantial evidence
for the inflationary origin of the
universe now George so these are kind of
like Eddie's in the Stream man exactly
checking in Eddie on the edge and so
yeah these are remnants of things that
happened extraordinarily early on you're
looking back past theoretically you're
looking back past 380 000 years
hey let me let me lay out for everybody
who's watching and listening just a a
brief schemata of time because you never
know there's all sorts of people
listening and you never know what people
know and what they don't know so let's
just take a walk through numbers so
everybody understands a thousand and
people generally know that a million is
a thousand thousand
but then things get murky at the top end
past then so a thousand million is a
billion and so we're looking at 13
000 millions or about 13 and 13.3 in
your estimation and right now we're
speaking about a time that's 300 000
years after the events of the Big Bang
but you're looking for you're looking
back even farther than that by looking
at the effects of the gravitational
waves on the microwave background and
that's what you built the telescope for
in the South Pole that's right so
imagine you're in a room right now uh
you're looking around your room you have
a horizon Beyond which you can't see
it's called the walls of the room that
you're in but if something happened
outside let's say somebody lit off a
firecracker outside of the room that
you're in you couldn't see it with light
but you could hear it with sound so in
other words you can see things that are
farther away and as we initiated our
conversation something that's farther
away we're seeing light from when it was
more primitive when it was older when it
was more distant means it translates by
the finite speed of light to an older
more primitive of existence so right if
the explosion was loud enough even if
you were deaf you could detect the
movement of the walls that's right yes
and so I I've heard that you know people
in the FBI you know they use the
vibration of Windows bouncing a laser
off the windows because people inside
the room are talking it's causing
reverberations of the glass and they can
read out and transduce the Sonic
vibrations of them air molecules using
the reverberations of glass and bouncing
a laser off it exactly like that right
we can see probably what they're doing
right now while we're talking uh space I
hope so it'd be a good use of their of
their bandwidth right
um so if you look back to that first as
I said we can go back from Friday today
13.8 billion years that someday we can
go back and and that first three minutes
of that day
formed the elements all the hydrogen
that's in your body's water all the
hydrogen that's in the oceans of the
entire planet and all planets perhaps
all of the hydrogen was formed in that
first three minute period but we can go
and celebrity let me okay let me ask you
a question about that because I I want
to get this exactly right and and it
also relates to something metaphysical
that I wanted to ask you about so when
we go back extraordinarily close to the
events of the big bang when things are
super hot and super dense we don't have
any of the elements that currently make
up the universe of matter as we know it
we have a state prior to the elemental
State and so what's what's the initial
State can you can you walk us through
the sequence of unfolding now people
should remember that the material world
that we see around us is made out of 114
elements some of which some of which are
man-made nor easily found in nature so
let's say a hundred just as a rule of
thumb and those elements differ in their
in the complexity of their atomic
structure and so the simpler elements
have you have neutrons and protons and
electrons that make up an atom and the
simpler the element is the fewer of the
neutrons and protons and electrons are
in the atomic structure so they're more
and more complicated clumps of of uh
subatomic particles of atomic particles
to make up the elements now they appear
in a sequence right as the universe
unfolds and so but before even hydrogen
which is the simplest uh Elemental
structure before hydrogen appears there
are other states of matter and that and
that sequences all the way back to the
Big Bang so can you unfold how the how
the periodic table emerges and then what
happens before that and then we'll go
back to the microwave and gravitational
wave story yeah so you know the famous
poet scientist Carl Sagan said you know
we Are All Made of Stars We're All Star
stuff uh and it's actually not really
true we're actually Cosmic stuff we're
actually most of us is water right
Jordan so most of water is hydrogen and
most of that hydrogen if not all of it
was formed during these first three
minutes after the big bang or again I'll
say that as a shorthand for the period
of time in which after before which we
lose uh information and we become
ignorant but uh but that period of time
leaves fossils and those fossils are the
hydrogen the helium that we see in the
universe and their Isotopes so there's
really only six or seven different
things that are made but without those
things they become the ingredients of
the first generation of stars those
generation of stars become nuclear
fusion reactors taking hydrogen nuclei
and Isotopes and fusing them together to
make helium after all Helios the name of
the Sun but the element helium was
discovered not on Earth on the sun I
always joke with my cosmology students
the the scientists had to go at night
you know for their own safety uh but but
helium was discovered not on Earth but
it was discovered on the sun via its
chemical Spectrum its chemical
fingerprint so the first elements
hydrogen and helium are formed in the
Big Bang much more helium is formed
later on in stars then that helium makes
heavier and heavier elements and we
start marching up the periodic table to
make the fill out the rest of those
hundred or so elements okay so we have
the big bang and the initial particles
or electromagnetic waves that emerge are
how would you how do you characterize
them is it how fast how long after the
big bang do you have the initial
hydrogen and its variant Isotopes and
what's there before that before it's
even hydrogen yeah so it doesn't become
hydrogen until 380 000 years later when
the universe is cool enough that a
proton can meet an electron and fuse
together if you like or condense to make
a actual atom and the first atoms in the
universe are formed then then afterwards
you get hydrogen combining to make
helium inside okay so so before that
it's just protons and electrons protons
they're not hanging out it's it's
exactly right they're in what's called
plasma so a plasma is the fourth state
of matter it's what happens when you
heat Beyond a gas you ionize you break
apart the atom into its constituent
nucleus and its electronic content so
you've got nucleus is positively charged
it's made of protons and neutrons and
the electrons are just separate uh
individualistic particles and there's
another type of particle which is very
important but we won't get into called
the neutrino and that that's actually
the only form of dark matter that we
know for sure exists so you've heard
about dark matter we've never observed
any other dark matter in the universe
besides a neutrino but they're not
relevant necessarily for either life or
what we have right
they have this plasma you have this
plasma of of protons electrons that
aren't aren't associating with one
another now that's a relatively uniform
field of very protons and electrons it's
super hot now it's only relatively
uniform and correct me if I've got this
wrong but I I looked into this a while
back so
it starts to Clump together and the
reason it clumps together is because of
gravitational attraction right clumps
together in material in in material well
clumps and the reason that that happens
is because of I believe it's because of
quantum uncertainty it isn't a hundred
percent uniform and so some particles
some of these primordial particles are a
little bit closer to others than than
others are there's a there's a slight
non uniformity about it and now and now
you get clumping and as the clumping
occurs it the the bigger the clump that
emerges the more likely it is to accrete
additional matter and then that keeps
happening until you get the beginning of
clumps of matter that are large enough
to be stars and then the stars have
enough gravitational force to produce
additional nuclear Trends or Atomic
Transformations and the Stars start to
generate the rest of the periodic table
of the elements
correct so far
yeah yeah so let me let me yeah go ahead
we can talk about how the rest of the
elements come into being as well yes
exactly
um so I'll get to your point about
curvature which is the Crux of
everything that you just said relies on
a very short word curvature that we have
to delineate but first I want to take a
slight detour if you'll indulge me with
your patented forbearance Jordan
um there is a lot of talk in the
Zeitgeist about artificial intelligence
and the dangers at which artificial
intelligence will pose to humanity some
say it's worse than nuclear war Elon
Musk has said such things
um others worry about more pedestrian
but still more important things like
loss of jobs and and meaning and and so
forth is very important to human
psychology
um I'm not so worried about artificial
intelligence and I'll tell you why the
reason relates to this famous gentleman
Albert Einstein we've mentioned him
three or four times already
um I don't know if you're familiar with
it Einstein called his happiest thought
Jordan Einstein called the uh a gedankin
experiment a thought experiment that he
alone did for the first time and the
following was conjectured by the great
uh Einstein he said that somebody if he
was falling if he was in an elevator and
the cable broke God forbid and the
elevators start to fall that person
would experience no gravitational force
it's called the Einstein equivalence
principle he called that the happiest
thought of his life now what does that
have to do with curvature and so on well
it turns out and artificial intelligence
let me first detour back to artificial
intelligence Jordan can I ask you how do
you expect a computer or an artificial
general intelligence could interpret
these two phenomena Free Fall the
visceral human-centered experience of
Free Fall A and B have a happiest
thought I want to ask you actually I'm
sorry to turn the tables on you uh for
me that gives me great comfort because
it really is occurring in the human mind
the human brain another thing that is of
infinite complexity and possibly
forbidden to our understanding behind an
ignorance Horizon like the big bang but
Jordan does that give you any Solace
because to me it's a great comfort that
it took a mind something trapped in the
wet super computer if you will on top of
our shoulders operating at room
temperature how can a computer
experience a visceral sensation if
possible and how could it ever associate
happiness with it
yeah well
um
that's a good question I don't know how
artificial intelligence systems will
mimic emotions I'm afraid that might be
more crackable than we think because
I've been talking to Carl friston for
example who's great neuroscientist and
one of the things he pointed out I had
figured out already because I had done
some work that was parallel to Kristen's
on the entropy management front and one
of the you could you can you can
characterize anxiety as the
neurophysiological response to the
unexpected emergence of entropy
so it's the reduction it's the expansion
of a single specified pathway forward
it's the expansion of that to multiple
Pathways so for example if you're
driving down the freeway and your car
breaks down the reason you get anxious
is because your car has been expanded
from the simple object that will move
you from point A to B to a set of a
complex and currently unsolvable
problems and that's signified by
negative emotion that anxiety is
proportionate to the degree to which
entropy is emerged and that's on the
negative emotion front and then on the
positive emotion front if you're moving
towards a valued goal with each
successful move forward you you decrease
the entropic distance between you and
the goal and that's signified by
positive emotion and it's possible that
AI systems will be able to at least
model this conceptually now that's
different than feeling it
qualitatively right this is we have a
feeling of anxiety yeah exactly whatever
that feeling means and that seems
irreducible in some sense but I think it
can be modeled mathematically and that
means that AI systems should be able to
conceptualize what constitutes the basis
for positive and negative emotion even
if they can't feel it feel it but that's
a mystery too because we don't know what
the hell feel means right yeah so
getting back to and actually I'm glad
that you brought up entropy because that
reduction in Phase space phase space
States is exactly what Einstein
effectively did in this thought
experiment he's saying right that's
exactly that's why he had positive
emotion that's exactly right because
exactly yeah yeah and in the context of
the physical so I I promise I'm I'm
absent-minded Professor but I'm not that
absent-minded going back to the
curvature conjecture that you mentioned
before everything hinges on curvature
everything hinges you nailed the Crux of
the issue it hints on curvature where
does that come from in Einstein's
conceptual general relativity he had two
great uh many many great ideas obviously
but special relativity has to do with
the finite speed of light and things
that travel near the speed of light
um and and the properties of such paths
through space in time and then gravity
is when you are General relativities
when you add in mass and gravity and
what that does to space time itself so
it turns out that there's uh the what
the effect of gravity is to do is to
curve and warp space-time now we
experience that on earth when we launch
a uh say you have a Canon as uh and you
shoot out a cannonball horizontally it
will eventually impact the Earth's
surface but it'll travel in a curved
parabolic Arc for a little bit of time
but if you shoot it with enough velocity
it can actually go into orbit around the
Earth that's also a curved path that
it's taking those are called geodesics
so it's TR it's actually tracking the
shape of the space time that it's
traveling through you can feel that if
you're on one of those merry-go-rounds
those kid merry-goers that's right yeah
you try to move your feet towards the
middle you can feel the the centrifugal
force you know move that's right legs as
you yeah but that's actually just and if
you're mature in space time that's local
that's right or if you've ever been here
to Sea World here in San Diego or you've
ever been on a car moving slightly
faster than maybe you should you go over
a bump for a moment you're suspended in
space time and then you come back down
it feels like that of course you're
actually traveling on what's called a
geodesic which is an entropically
minimizing so it's order producing it's
producing a a translational map through
space-time that minimizes your path
length uh just like if you travel from
uh you know Miami to London you don't
take a straight line you take an a
geodesic path that brings you closer to
the North Pole than then you would
ordinarily expect but as you experience
that that is the manifestation on Earth
of the mass of the Earth but remember
what we're you're trying to figure out
is how did that mass come to be in the
clump that we call the Earth and how did
the Galaxy that surrounds us come to be
in the place well that means that there
had to be some place for matter and mass
to agglomerate to fall into to coalesce
to eventually make the Galaxy that has
the sun in it and the sun to have the
material that orbits around it that we
call the Earth
those fluctuations in the background
otherwise Perfection of space-time
uniformity I would say if if if you know
we're everything was completely perfect
we wouldn't be here having this
conversation right right right
still distributed yeah yeah yeah that's
right it'll be a very boring universe so
people often in science Jordan are
driven and my scientific colleagues are
driven by a notion of beauty and Beauty
has Symmetry and symmetry is a
manifestation of underlying order and
Perfection well I say to them the
universe should be incredibly boring if
the universe was actually driven by
symmetry it's actually the deviations
from symmetry the variations the
perturbations that lead to all the
interesting phenomena that we that we
know and love right you've seen this
experiment so just that that tiny DV
that's so interesting that it's a tiny
reminds me of uh of of of of a Buddhist
minimum minimalist art you know where
there's there's an art piece where
everything is perfect except for one
thing that's left that's left in
disarray and there's a whole lot art
form a whole Japanese art form that's
associated with that and so so why do
you believe that it was the curvature
that was there at the beginning of time
that was responsible for the lack of
homogeneity rather than Quantum
uncertainty in relationship to the
location of the particles or are that is
that the same thing or are there
alternative theories they're related so
the overarching framework by which
curvature provides the primordial seeds
for later matter to agglomerate to then
collapse and sub-nuclear fusion ignition
and then the the movie plays forward as
we described it or you described it
before so the initial conditions how did
those curvature perturbations get there
in the first place well if the universe
was smaller than an atom uh even though
we don't manifest these large-scale
perturbations today in a Quantum field
we don't sense quantum mechanics in any
discernible Sense on the scale of an
atom if we were atom sized uh then we
would see Quantum effects all the time
we would see the input and output of
virtual particles
um which you know later become things
like Hawking radiation all sorts of
other things but in the early Universe
this would manifest itself as departures
from perfect homogeneity by one part and
one hundred thousand so let me give you
an idea
um uh you ever go bowling Jordan and you
have a bowling ball the surface of the
bowling ball is more rough than the
surface if you like the smoothness
relative to its characteristic scale in
other words the the fluctuations of the
bowling ball surface relative to its
radius are far smoother than the uni are
far rougher than the universe and uh was
at this extremely early time a fraction
of a second before uh what we then
produce the elements that we spoke about
before now that surface to the bowling
ball is pretty smooth unless it's my
bowling ball which has all these dents
in it but but but the point being the uh
the universe is incredibly small smooth
and so you only have to manifest tiny
little perturbations but that's what
inflation does inflation says I didn't
get to this before but when we made this
detection in 2014 that's described in my
book losing Nobel Prize we claimed we
detected these waves of gravity that's
as close as scientists think we can get
to the detecting The Smoking Gun it's
actually the smoke from the gun if you
will of the initial inflationary
expansion of the universe now with
inflation
concomitantly unavoidably inextricably
linked is the notion of the Multiverse
okay you cannot have inflation which
means you cannot have these Quantum
perturbations that you were describing
which means that the framework then
collapses once you go forward unless you
have a Multiverse so the lot so let's
let's walk people through what inflation
is first and then talk about the
relationship between that and the
Multiverse so so yeah explain it explain
inflation and explain why it was
necessitated as a theoretical and then
an experimentally validated construct or
an experimentally investigated so we
live in a Quantum Universe we don't
detect it because we're kind of these
macroscopic creatures right we're sort
of you know a couple meters
characteristic scale we live for you
know tens of decades hopefully uh but
but we don't live you know we don't
observe things that the nanosecond or
picosecond scale we don't observe things
at the uh femtometer uh size scale so
we're it's kind of hidden To Us by an
averaging process that our brain you've
spoken about this many times we have a
foveal kind of attention that we pay to
objects and Beyond what which we can't
really say anything other than vague
Notions about so we can only focus on
the foveal analogy to us is that we are
all focused on things that are our size
so it's natural to think about that we
don't see Quantum Tigers coming out of
the vacuum and then disappearing right
so our mind has to work and make
analogies so we analogize the universe
today as being filled with Quantum
fields and then the particles are just
instantiations of those Quantum Fields
so there's a proton field over here
that's making this dust particle or this
air molecule there's a photon field
there's a particles of light
etc etc the imagine the universe the
cosmos as you know it is filled with an
infinite tapestry of potentiality it can
be a photon over here there may not be a
photon over here depends on the value of
that Quantum okay so what that's so
that's so interesting that idea of an
infinite expanse of potentiality because
potentiality is a very strange
um what would you call it scientific
materialist concept because only what's
real can be measured materially
but we need this hypothesis of something
approximating an infinite potential and
you know I don't know if you know this
about I would say my work but it's not
just my work it's the entire Corpus of
symbolic thought uh as insofar as that's
been interpreted let's say by
psychoanalytic thinkers there is a
hypothesis uh cosmological hypothesis
that permeates religious speculation
that the the cosmos that's inhabitable
so the structured material world is a
manifestation of a multi uh what a
multiplicitous potential that's chaos
that's the that's the infinite chaos
right and so in Genesis for example
there's a process that looks to me to be
akin to communicative Consciousness that
interacts with something approximating
an infinite potential that's
yeah exactly that exactly that and it's
that the implica that the order that is
good is extracted out from this
multi-dimensional
it's not multi-dimensional
multi-potential field of potential as a
consequence of the of the action of some
structuring Force right and that's the
that's the cosmologically generative
principle and so it's very interesting
to me that in the realm of physics
itself which people consider the queen
of science sciences that there is the
notion of of this expansive potential
and you Associated that with with with
Quantum fields and also with the
Multiverse and so so yeah let's walk
through all of that
it's even deeper than that as you're
saying the potentiality is something
intrinsic to not only the existence of
our universe but there's a mirror
universe that you I know have been
equated you know familiarized with with
sir Roger Penn and that's the that's the
anti-universe the fact that we have
anti-matter and and is possible to look
at the work of Dirac we talk about the
Dirac C where there's an infinite set of
potential states that are filled and
occupied uh or occupied and depending on
their potentiality versus their
actuality when do they get instantiated
when do they get commanded into
existence to use a a very overburdened
phrase right so so this and there's
what's called solid state physics or
condensed matter Theory we have um
imagine you have uh you know a bunch of
people a crowd uh on a regular grid and
they're all moving and then one guy gets
teleported by some aliens that will have
to talk about some other time so the one
guy gets teleported out of this infinite
grid of people marching as soldiers
right
um and then and then the soldiers kind
of get nervous so they start moving to
fill in that hole so one moves to fill
in the hall where the soldier has been
uh extracted or you know rendered out of
existence and then that produces a hole
in another place where that other
Soldier was right so there's a sea of
the now you start to see this hole
moving but is the whole real Jordan I
mean the the guys are real right but now
that one guy left and so they're filling
in so now there's this other thing
called a hole and it's moving and
there's an exact analogy between that
and what's called condensed matter
physics that are called phonons not
photons but phonons and how they
propagate and they have properties they
travel at some speed so now you're
talking about the absence of something
the potentiality of that which was and
it is propagating in a sea of
possibilities as well so I'm not sure
the Sea of par the Sea of potentiality
my students and I tried to work through
the relationship between anxiety and
entropy and we were contemplating the
the the Horizon of possibility because I
think that what people what
Consciousness does is confront a horizon
of possibility it's not something driven
in an algorithmic deterministic manner
by the states of material objects at the
current time it contends with the Sea of
probably of potentiality but it also
appears and maybe this is a consequence
of the principles of existence itself
that that sea of probability is
structured in a in a normal distribution
of probability so for example the most
probable next event in our conversation
is that one or the other of us or both
will utter a word
but there's some non-zero probability
that there'll be a cataclysmic
earthquake and I'll be swallowed up by
the ground right it's now it's it's
relatively low probability of that thank
God but it's not zero and it's not
entirely predictable not in San Diego
probability it's more higher probability
that means exactly exactly exactly well
in the cataclysmic events in our life
occur when something that we deem of
relatively low probability in this set
of infinite part potential actually
makes itself manifest and the more
unlikely that event according to our
conceptual schema the more anxiety is
associated with it but is there a is
there a sense among physicists that this
infinite sea of possibility you you
describe the relationship to dirac's
thought and I didn't know about that is
there some notion that some of those
states are more likely to emerge given
the current state than others and is
that a way of conceptualizing some
alternative to determinism Yeah we
actually had you know a concept that you
know we could turn to probably another
topic but Richard Feynman one of the
Titanic physicists of the of the last
hundred years came up with this kind of
sum over histories or a path and a path
integral description by which particles
get from A to B by taking sampling all
paths in which they could possibly take
you know going for me and you directly
but going the opposite way too and those
get weighted with different or lesser
probabilities to use the language that
you were just saying but I want to touch
back one more to what you said who
Feynman development that's right that's
right and and so I see when you spoke
about this anxiety I wanna I do you know
because I I can't I can't resist Jordan
as a podcaster myself to you know how
often do I have the chance to uh to
interview somebody like you uh even
though this is your your conversation I
want to continue with your questions uh
but but there's something that you said
and I hope again you'll indulge me with
your forbearance
um you mentioned anxiety and entropy I
want to ask you right now
um you know how many different ways
could I make your life twice as good
like or 10 times as good how many ways
could I do that I mean there's a very
finite number of ways yeah exactly and
there's a well that's a very good
observation that's that's part of I
think why we're also weighted towards
waiting negative emotion more
significantly is that the number of ways
things can go wrong is near infinite
whereas the number of ways things can be
improved is that's the that's the
straight narrow path right that's also
by the way the boundary between Order
and Chaos in the in the Taoist
conceptualization of the world it's a
very narrow Pathway to make things
better it's not impossible but it's very
difficult it's not to make things but I
think Jordan and I want to run this by
you my my theory is that you should lean
into that which would devastate you in
other words you and I are both parents
you've met my children
um you you know that you know the the
greatest fears I don't even have to
speak it you know God forbid but but
anyone who's had brought a life into
existence has organized entropy has
reduced entropy has invested so much
into this into this beautiful creature
miracle that we call a child and and
that's just one example of how your life
could be made not twice as worse or ten
times worse it could be made infinitely
worse but I like to invert that and use
that as a guiding principle and get your
get your impressions about that because
it seems to me that we should be doing
those things and making those Network
enter entropic connections that we
should have as many of them that they
would if removed would would devastate
Us in other words you can find out what
you should well okay so one of the
I would say that that's one of the most
fundamental contributions of New
Testament thinking to Old Testament
thinking it it emerges in part as a
consequence you could say uh narrative
consequence of the conundrums that's
that are brought forward in the Book of
Job so the Book of Job is a narrative
description of the infinite numbers of
potential ways you can profoundly suffer
and so job is not only ill in the most
terrible ways and innocently ill but
he's ill in a way that loses any
simultaneously loses his wife and his
family and then his friends make fun of
him for being ill and and accuse him of
being sinful that's the reason for his
illness and so he's at the bottom of the
deepest possible pit and he has he
contends with God as a consequence in
some ways attempting to negotiate with
the Divine to understand why it is that
he's been condemned to suffering now it
turns out in that story that God made a
bet with Satan of all things that if
Satan tortured job that or job that it
lives job would lose his faith right so
it's a very strange story but but uh
Carl Jung wrote a great book called
answer to job that takes that apart
great detail but what happens in the
Christian story is a strange inversion
of the story of job because the
hypothesis in the Christian story is
essentially that
the best way through the absolute
catastrophe of life is to voluntarily
take on the deepest possible set of
catastrophes as if they are an
encouraging challenge it's something
like that that's you can think about
that metaphysically as the invitation to
the cross and so the notion is analogous
to the notion that you're describing
which is the best way
to
inoculate yourself against catastrophe
is to confront it voluntarily it's the
same idea by the way as the notion that
the larger dragons hoard more gold and
the dragon gold story is a very very old
story and the notion there is that the
best what you could find that would
manifest itself as the best in your life
is likely to be found as Jung said in
stir quilliness inventure which meant
that which you most need will be default
be found where you least want to look
right so the cave that you fear to enter
holds the treasure you seek I think
Campbell's exactly well you know in your
life one of the things you pointed out
and and uh we will talk about this maybe
in in the daily wire uh interview you
know you had to deal with the loss of
your father and which was a very dark
thing to lose very dark thing to
contemplate and you know you said that
one of the things you did as a
consequence of contemplating that
relatively forthrightly was develop a
certain kind of uh radical ambition both
in terms of enthusiasm because you're
interested it but also in terms of the
magnitude of the problem that you were
setting out to challenge and so you
simultaneously solved the psychological
and metaphysical Problem by delving into
the structure of the real at the place
that looked darkest and most mysterious
to you and I think that is it's
something everyone should know I've been
lecturing to my audiences as I go around
the world more recently talking about
how Destiny makes itself manifest to
people and it does that by inviting you
with opportunities that sees your
imagination but it also does it by
calling out to you certain problems that
beset you that happen to be your
problems whatever that means you know
because it's not like it's not like
you're obsessed by an infinite number of
problems you're obsessed by that set of
problems that happen for whatever reason
to be your problems and you might say
well I wish I didn't have any problems
but then you don't have any mystery the
reverse of that would be to say well I'm
going to take the worst problem that
besets me and delve into that most
deciduously and I think the evidence is
quite clear on the clinical front that
that's how you find the Great Adventure
of your life
I think that's a universal truth by the
way yeah I think this and I see this
with Scientists you know the the issue
that uh you know that most people don't
really recognize is that science is done
by scientists you know we're not walking
automatons that to have no feeling and
have nothing invested in it and that's
why I think it was sort of like almost
like a coming out you know feeling must
be I'm not familiar with it but but you
know Liberation when you recognize your
own particular Dragon if you're willing
to solve it look I mean you mentioned
the mystery and what perplexes you so if
your car breaks down and the analogy
used before it causes you anxiety but
you know exactly what you have to do you
have to you know get a Jack and you have
to put the tire on and you have to get
on your way and hopefully you'll be
there on time uh but but but you know
what the path is and it's not that
mysterious I've been thinking about
scientists you know we're we're
confronted with an infinite you know
spectrum of of mysteries on a daily
basis and the rabbi uh Jonathan sacks I
don't know if you ever met him he's the
one one of the guests a few guests that
I never got to have on my podcast but
Johnson sex was a chief Rabbi of of the
United Kingdom and The Commonwealth and
uh he has this kind of brilliant take he
wrote a book on called the Grand
partnership about the reconciliation and
the committee between religion and
Science and and one of the things he
would speculate on was you know why is
it that scientists are the least
religious you know I actually happen to
think that scientists are incredibly
religious and yes so we should talk more
about that because I yeah I'd like to
know why you think that yeah we'll get
to that before we part here yeah let's
do that yep uh so you know thinking
about scientists we are confronted with
mysteries on on on on this daily basis
but getting back to the ultimate mystery
you know of why are we here why why you
know scientists aren't used to answering
why questions and and it's almost like
it's beyond our domain but we don't like
that Jordan right because scientists I
think I think you can correct me again
if I'm wrong in any way but I think
there's a narcissistic trait behind
scientists that's a good thing I you
know we have this concept in Judaism of
a Yates or Hara an evil inclination and
a yet sirhatov a good inclination but
it's like the yin yang there's a there's
a little bit of each in each one in
other words your evil inclination your
your your desire for Glory in the Nobel
Prize and and so they can actually cause
you to transmute that into gold and do
things that are good for you and and and
and and likely the the the positive
qualities you want everybody you know to
to to to think the right way or whatever
that means you want everyone to get a
vaccine or you know you can think you're
doing good and that can actually not be
good right so so the the point that I'm
trying to make is if you if you don't
channel the propensity of a scientist to
think solipsistically and
narcissistically if you if you don't do
it and I don't know how to do it with my
students right I'm supposed to teach
them the what questions but I don't get
to teach them the why questions
we'll be right back first we wanted to
give you a sneak peek at Jordan's new
series Exodus
so the Hebrews created history as we
know it
I think and some
bend the fabric of reality and that you
can treat people instrumentally and that
you can bow to the Tyrant and violate
your conscience without cause you will
pay the piper it's going to call you out
of that slavery into Freedom even if
that pulls you into the desert
[Music]
there's something else going on here
that is far more Cosmic and deeper than
what you can imagine the highest
[Music]
intended precisely as that spirit that
allies itself with the cause of Freedom
against tyranny I want villains to get
punished but do you want the villains to
learn before they have to pay the
ultimate price that's such a Christian
question
okay so there's a couple of things here
we'll go back to the scientists uh uh
are more religious than they presume
they are they partly because they
believe in the in the presumption of
Redemptive truth they believe there is a
logos in the world an order that can be
discovered through rational apprehension
and experimentation empirical
experimentation but they also believe
that the truth will set you free because
otherwise you wouldn't do science and
that was the way in that I used when I
was trying to train my graduate students
to be ethical researchers so now as you
said a sign someone who does science is
a person a scientist and so a person
above all and then a scientist and the
consequence of that is that that person
has to be concerned with such mundane
realities as formulating a career and
that isn't only self-promotion because
there's no bloody point in discovering
something unless you communicate it to
people unless you have a network that
you've developed you can't communicate
it and so it's part and parcel of the
scientific Endeavor but then and you
might ask yourself what should be
Paramount right the promotion of your
career and the communication of your
findings in which case you get false
research findings all the time or the
truth and part of the answer to that is
you know if you're not assiduous in your
pursuit of the truth then you could
easily so if I have a student who does a
master's or PhD piece of research and
they pee hack so they claim that they
found valid results when they didn't
because they muck about at the micro
level with the application then well
then as they swallow that lie they're
going to convince themselves that what
they discovered was actually true and
then they're going to convince other
people and then there's going to be a
whole set of them that are going down an
entirely pathological and false Road and
so part of the reason that even if you
are interested in promoting your career
which you should be to some degree the
reason you should abide by the truth is
because you have to ask yourself whether
or not you want to spend your entire
life investigating something that
doesn't exist merely to in inflate your
status among your peers and with anyone
sensible like because you could have
your cake and eat it too you know you
could look at where you're wrong as a
scientist and find the interesting
stumbling blocks and the interesting
Mysteries you could dive into that then
you could discover something real and
you could have status among your peers
and be acclaimed as someone who had a
genuine contribution and build a
communication Network and that's a way
better plan than being
um that what would you say then falling
prey to falsehood and and warping the
entire field that's all unethical that's
all an issue of fundamental ethics which
we never teach to our student process no
we never teach that to our students I
mean at least sorry in the physical
sciences I mean my law school my medical
school colleagues even my business
school colleagues I I don't know about
you Jordan but I was never taught to
teach right so this is my job this is
and I think for you too I think you know
on your Tombstone may it be at age 120
uh Jordan but I think it'll say you know
father husband teacher some some order
like that because because I think the
essence of who you are like I'm a pilot
too I fly little tiny planes in Southern
California little Cessnas around okay
um when I became a pilot it changed who
I was I started to think about the world
look I'm not only you know a physicist
or a father whatever I'm a pilot and
it's a part of a core identification I
also felt that way as a professor and I
know that you felt that way as a
professor even if you're not teaching
you know on a daily basis and and we can
get into your the travails the awful way
that you've been brutally you know kind
of uh set about by monsters in your own
right uh some other time uh but but I
just want to point out that we never get
taught how to teach we never get taught
at least in the physical sciences maybe
and we almost get get these these
ethical conundrum that you just
mentioned
um you know we we get the barest minimum
of kind of ethical training in a
one-page sheet that you sign and you
maybe watch a two-minute video uh that
some a consulting firm was paid eighty
thousand dollars to make but but this
the point is that you do have the
tendency and this is a in part with my
first book losing the Nobel Prize is
about it's about wanting to discover
something that's not only viscerally
connected to you and your career and
making a living for yourself and your
family which as you said is by no means
a trivial thing I mean we're human
beings we have to support and and
there's and and there's a lot to be said
about good honest work and the work that
colleagues and I uh are engaged in but
we were confronted with the discovery of
a lifetime and that would not only mean
as I said before that we had discovered
you know gravitational waves which had
never been uh observed in this fashion
and in 2014 when we made this
announcement at Harvard
um uh uh you know that we had discovered
the aftershocks of the inflationary
Epoch but that we had discovered
evidence for the Multiverse and and yet
what did it get undone by the most
humble meager make substance in the
whole world which in the universe which
is called dust and I thought it was so
ironic but it's a teachable thing we
succumb to what Feynman the great
Feynman that we mentioned before he said
the first principle is that you should
not fool yourself and the second
principle is that you are the easiest
person to fool and and that be speaks of
what's called confirmation bias the P
hacking and stuff that's Downstream as
you said the piac and the replication
crisis in your field and by the way it's
starting to become a crisis in my field
oh and things like room temperature of
course most but most discoveries aren't
real if if science progressed at five
percent a year in real fact and so 95
percent of it was tripe we were still
Progressive oh yeah five percent
knowledge increment a year that's that's
right and so what okay so what happened
on the dust front and then I want to
tell you a little story from Exodus and
then we should pop up this section so
what happened on the dust front
so in the dust front uh we were so
consumed with this notion and I want to
speak mostly for me although I I know
that it did afflict colleagues involved
with this uh for me as I said before it
represented the greatest Idol the the
Talisman of all not just of society not
just of science Jordan you have to
imagine when people run to be president
of the United States they always get
whoever's running on the Democratic side
gets a letter from 70 Nobel Prize
winners uh about why you know the
Democrats should be president
um when there was uh the the covid
vaccine or the sorry the the gain of
function research was being sponsored by
the Eco Health Alliance by Peter dashik
and fauci 70 Nobel Prize winners wrote
to president Trump to say this is wrong
you shouldn't cancel the gain of
function research and people can invest
in other words Nobel Prize carries
weight punches way above its weight loss
it doesn't just affect Egghead boffins
in the laboratory it does and it does
affect my funding probability and how
many people we can hire in a given field
and what the direction of the field may
be but it percolates to the front page
of the New York Times as well so it's
the most
um you know kind of highest example of
an idol and I always look back you know
when when you we talk about Exodus maybe
we'll talk about the the sin of the
golden calf which is a very natural
thing but when you actually see Jordan
that that scientists will give their eye
teeth and they will literally Bow Down
to the king of Sweden and accept a
gilded engraven image I mean the the
mapping of the of the symbolism could
not be more uh more perfect if you wrote
it in a Hollywood script but it comes
directly out of Exodus and in our case
in my case this Idol that I had worship
uh and set so much of my being my my my
psychology towards
um that it could be undone what it it
came it worried me but it didn't it
didn't cause me to pull the plug and to
not go forward or to say Over My Dead
Body are we going to publish this and
what ended up happening is we saw the
pattern of polarization called curling
polarization this whirlpools these
Eddies that you spoke about earlier and
that bespeaks of the inflationary origin
of the universe because if the universe
were filled with a Quantum field at its
earliest moments and perhaps in
perpetuity via uh the the the uh what's
called the inflaton this would then be
the field in which reverberations could
take place those reverberations are the
curvature perturbations that you asked
about uh a while ago those provided the
nucleation sites for matter to collapse
condense agglomerate into which then
ignited the Stars which then made the
Supernova which then made us so the
story is an incred incredible story it
hinges on inflation being correct
inflation hinges upon a Quantum field
called the inflaton and the inflaton
hinges upon a super arching structure
called the Multiverse for it to be
filling in other words inflation didn't
just happen once Jordan it didn't happen
twice it happened an infinite number of
times and it's happening right now and
it's unavoidable to because it cannot be
sort of superseded it cannot be shut off
and yet and yet
because we live in a galaxy a galaxy is
a very very dirty place it's a place
filled with asteroids and subatomic
particles and charged particles and it's
filled with the most humble substance
that's left over and thank God thank
bloody God as you might say that it does
exists because we are as Carl Sagan
called the earth a moat of dust riding
on a Sunbeam in other words the Earth is
a giant block of dust the the iron in
the hemoglobin molecule that powers your
body right now came from that Supernova
that produced the dust that obscured and
mimicked with perfect Fidelity the
signal that I was hell-bent and my
colleagues were hell-bent on detecting
it mimicked the curl mode polarization
signal to a T and we saw what we wanted
to see and best of all it meant that we
had seen the Multiverse people on the
front pages of every headline every
newspaper from San Diego to New York to
CNN
we have detected the first physical
evidence
for the Multiverse okay so let's walk me
through that because I still I don't
quite understand it so you you talked
about the fact that the initial Quantum
perturbations that existed prior to the
um to our ability to detect the
background radiation
were were a consequence of gravitational
waves and we talked a little bit about
the fact that those perturbations could
be mimicked by the by Cosmic dust the
the perturbation induced polarization
could be mimicked by Cosmic dust so was
the polarization you detected a
consequence of the quantum fluctuation
or was it a secondary consequence of the
of polarization by this by this by this
widely dispersed dust so when you came
to visit San Diego I gave you some
chunks of rock they look like ordinary
chunks of rock but they're actually
meteorites and actually I give them away
on my website for free you know I I have
these giveaways where people can get
it's a meteorite it's actually what you
see is a meteor shower when some of the
material in a meteor shower reaches the
Earth's surface it's called a meteorite
and that meteorite that I gave you and I
give away on occasion to people who go
to my website
um is a chunk of iron and it's iron it's
Cobalt it's nickel I also will send
people the uh the chemical assay of it
as well because it's just so cool to see
that this chunk of rock is 4.3 billion
years old it may it predates the the
Earth formation and it shares a lot in
common with the Earth one thing it
shares in common with the Earth is that
it has a magnetic susceptibility if you
take that little meteorite that I gave
you and you put it next to a
refrigerator magnet it'll suck onto that
like a like a parasite sucking on a on a
on a brain okay uh that that suction is
due to the magnetic properties of iron
which is a ferromagnet and that will
attach to a magnetic field just like the
Earth does those magnetic fields are not
confined to the Earth Jordan the galaxy
has a magnetic field the universe as a
as a whole may have a magnetic field but
what happened was there's these
particles of meteorites in our local
region of the Milky Way galaxy through
which we are always looking like a dirty
window like looking through a dirty
window there's unavoidable we live in a
galaxy so we we'd have to go outside the
Galaxy which is which is technologically
and almost theoretically impossible and
go out outside to get away from this
dust so we're stuck inside this Dusty
Cloud this Dusty region again thank God
for it because without it there wouldn't
be blood in our veins and there wouldn't
be a planet for us to sit on so it it's
a chimera it it gives and it takes away
in this case it took away the Nobel
Prize because the magnetic field of our
galaxy can cause the same twisting
curling Eddies of the emission from
these meteorites or these dust particles
as well and that provided the chimeric
illusion that we had seen exactly
Fidelity to the origin if the universe
began with inflation the exact same
pattern it's almost devilish it's almost
satanic because it exactly mimicked it
and of course we knew about it we
weren't you know babe babes in the woods
we didn't make a blunder you know we
didn't put our Thumb in the front of the
lens cap or you know but we did our job
but we we d-weighted that probability we
assessed it we said uh it's not like as
likely as the explanation that we found
of course the the opposite is true right
to say that the Universe began out of a
spawn nucleation site within the
Multiverse providing curvature sites for
agglomerations of that's a much much
Wilder story to believe in retrospect
than oh we detected dust from our galaxy
but the I do I don't want to condemn my
myself too much too harshly or my
colleagues too because we immediately
tried not only to falsify that
hypothesis but we work with another team
which was our competitor which is a
billion dollar satellite called the
Planck satellite and they had been hot
on the trail the exact same signal as us
science is very competitive you know you
mentioned all these different traits of
science scientists all the time yeah I
always say scientists are like children
right we're we're curious we're playful
we're Whimsical but just like children
we don't like to play with others we're
we're you know we're jealous we're
petting we have all the good qualities
of of children but we it's a
double-edged sword we have some of the
negative some of those are the desire
for credit and for affirmation and for
attention I'm speaking for me
specifically here but this is a very
common Affliction especially when the
stakes are as high as they are to say
that we live in a Multiverse which is
the direct conclusion of this discovery
if it had held up which it did not so
the results were so what's the stat
what's the status of the uh Quantum
fluctuation field agglomeration Theory
now you didn't provide evidence that it
was the case right is that still the
extant theory in relationship yes to the
initial agglomeration of matter it is it
is it is validate that theory
you're claimed to have provided evidence
for it exactly and we made the most
precise uh detection ever of this type
of signal it's just the interpretation
was wrong we didn't make a blunder we
didn't say there's faster than light
neutrinos or whatever we made an
exquisitely precise measurement of dust
in our galaxy which is useful by the way
because what we see we'll never see a
unit well as I said until we get out of
the Galaxy which won't even happen you
know with with with trillions of dollars
of funding it's it's physically
impossible right so until we're always
going to be measuring a combined signal
a potential Cosmic signal plus an actual
dust signal so now with other
experiments including the experiment
that I lead with my colleagues at the
University of Pennsylvania at Princeton
at Berkeley in Chicago called the Simons
Observatory funded by Jim Simons at the
Simons foundation in Maryland Simons
um and that project is 110 million
dollar project in the Atacama Desert of
Northern Chile which has as one of its
tools as one of its pieces of apparatus
Jordan has a dust detection experiment
so the only way to get rid of a
systematic experiment a systematic
contaminant is to dedicate a whole new
experiment to it imagine you've got your
thumb on the scale and you're pouring
your coffee beans in you're going to get
too few coffee oh I do another
experiment and this trivia just I saw my
thumbs on the scale for us we have to do
a separate experiment we have to
dedicate some of our extremely
exquisitely produced detectors my
colleague Suzanne Staggs at Princeton
makes these no one's ever made anything
like what she's been able to do with her
group and they detect the the the
faintest possible microwave signals from
The Big Bang but they can also detect
dust so she's dedicated some control for
it now exactly so she has channels
Jordan that only measure dust which if
you had told me 25 years ago you're
going to be measuring dust I'd say I
thought I was interested in the biggest
questions yeah if I want to study dust I
can follow my my you know my teenager
around right I don't I don't need like
to build a hundred million dollar Pro no
we measure the combined total signal
we'll subtract the dust signal what will
be left is the cosmic signal and we hope
to have first light or first microwave
of that instrument in the coming next
year
oh well congratulations on that so let
me close this up with this Exodus story
because I think it's relevant to well
the metaphysical speculations we've been
indulging in but also I think it's
biographically relevant so when Moses
before Moses emerges as a as a leader of
his people he encounters the burning
bush and that's a very interesting story
because what happens is Moses is
basically out for a stroll and something
attracts his attention now it's not a
burning oak tree it's not a volcano it's
something that flickers and glimmers on
the edge of his perception you might say
it attracts them so it attracts his
curiosity and he decides that he's going
to investigate that which attracts his
curiosity now the burning bush is a
paradoxical manifestation because it's
being and that would be the bush or the
tree the small tree that's alive that's
being but it's also becoming because
fire is an agent of transformation and
so the burning bush is a symbol of the
the Paradox of existence which is that
things are and are becoming at the same
time and so
Moses is attracted by this and he
decides to investigate it to inquire
into its nature and the consequence of
his inquiry into its nature is that the
voice of being itself speaks to him
right and that's basically how God
announces himself he says I am that I am
or I am that I will be or I was that I
am now it's it's a statement of the
essence of being and the idea behind
that story is that if you assiduously
pursue that which attracts your
attention the voice of being itself will
speak the ultimate truth to you and
that's a hell of a thing to understand
and so when you're trying to teach your
students ethics you can say look you can
subjugate the the search for truth to
your venal ambition but the cost of that
will be that if the voice of God beckons
to you from the unknown you'll miss it
and if you think about that for like 30
seconds and you have any wisdom at all
there isn't a chance in hell that if you
were the least bit wise that you would
put the exigencies of your ambition even
if their Nobel Prize uh oriented above
the possibility that the structure of
reality itself could reveal itself to
you as a consequence of you having the
delightful opportunity to pursue what
most uh what effectively attracts your
interest there isn't a better deal than
that and scientists who are real
scientists are imbued by that desire and
they believe it too because they do
believe that if they investigate
something no matter how trivial dust
let's say no matter how contemptible
that the consequence of that will be
that they will be able to appear into
the furthest expanses of of what would
you say the sacred fundamental realities
of existence itself and all of that
seems to be true so that's a good
ethical lesson for students to know that
is yeah to be open to what your eyes can
see right the the Taurus speaks about
being able to hear the Shema the
catechism of the Jewish faith is hear
not see don't follow after what your
heart leads you astray it actually says
to prop to prostitute to prostitute
yourself after what your heart wants no
here here is a passive but you can be
sensitized to it now I absolutely
appreciate that Jordan I appreciate that
yeah well that's also a matter of of
rather than thinking and imposing your
desire onto the phenomena which is what
you said you were tempted by and you
described why is that you have to let
the phenomena speak for itself and
phenomena by the way means shine forth
that's the original derivation of the
term so a phenomena is something that
shines forth right and it does in fact
attract your attention and if you pay
enough attention then well you'll be
rewarded for what you pay and you'll be
rewarded by a glimpse into the structure
of things and that can help you
reconcile yourself to the catastrophe of
existence itself right by peering into
that underlying structure and to feel as
a consequence in some manner in
harmonious relationship to the cosmos
itself and there isn't a better price
than not no there isn't that's right
all right well for everyone watching and
listening um that was a brief walk
through the entire structure of
cosmological reality at a relatively low
resolution but in a very interesting
Manner and so thank you for taking us on
a 90 minute long 13.8 billion year trip
uh it's much appreciated uh appreciate
you taking the time to talk to me today
and to answer all my questions and to
everyone who's watching and listening
your time and attention is always
appreciated and not taken for granted to
the Daily wire plus people for making
this conversation possible for
facilitating it that's also much
appreciated they bring that all to you
all of you who are listening on YouTube
uh that's all courtesy of the daily wire
that's a big deal on their part a real
Public Service as far as I'm concerned
and to the film crew here in where the
hell am I
um
oh yes I'm in Miami I'm in Miami in
Florida and so uh and doing this podcast
I'm going to continue to speak to Dr
Keating for another 30 minutes on the
daily wire plus platform about some of
the autobiographical issues that we
described and uh if you guys are
interested in pursuing this conversation
further in a more psychological
Direction then uh jump on over to daily
wear plus and if you don't have a
subscription consider supporting them
and uh in any case thank you very much
Dr Keating it was wonderful talking to
you and to everybody who is listening
and watching ciao we'll see you again
execution's 11 p.m but he's trying to
convince us he's gone insane therefore
incapable of being executed Edward
Edward I am a demon demons are anything
starting to happen can you feel it
it's time we tell you what it is that
we'd like you to do
nefarious in theaters April 14th rated R
hello everyone I would encourage you to
continue listening to my conversation
with my guest on dailywireplus.com